on enlève les tensions angelo semblent
plus détendus et cela grâce au massage
sa mère katherine est venu assister à
cet atelier dirigé sous les conseils de
séverine on nous montre qu'on est là
qu'on se prépare en frais sauf les nains
petite pression sur les pieds massage
papillon pour les jambes
la mère de famille apprend les bons
gestes pour un massage relaxant
il ne faut jamais lâcher le contact avec
son bébé lors du massage
l'enfant doit toujours vous sentir vous
pouvez placer vos pouces au niveau du
front et vous laisser un deux trois
petits chefs et on lit ces sorciers
ces massages stimule le développement
sensoriel il est conseillé de les faire
sur le lit parental et d'instaurer un
rituel lumière tamisée et musicalement
fond c'est un massage bien-être par un
massage thérapeutique et
c'est surtout un moment privilégié avec
entre l'enfant et son parent des
massages aux visages sont également
appris lors de l'atelier ils peuvent
soulager notamment la poussée des dents
des tout petits la mer d'angelo profite
de ce moment de partage avec son fils
c'est pour créer un lien et que et que
ça descend ça permet de détendre passe à
montrer villégier ensemble et faire une
petite parenthèse dans la vie du
quotidien
ça m'a donné encore plus envie de se
poursuivre dans ce sens là et puis de
d'apprendre de nouveaux gestes pour
masser mon bébé j'ai l'impression que ça
lui a fait du bien
donc c'est que du bonheur un moment de
douceur entre parents et enfants qui se
reproduira à domicile